[Applause]
well the golden knights are settling
into their new season yes they are off
on their first long road trip of the
season but without some of their top
players ron futrell joins us now with
the latest ron yeah kirsten christian
the knights are heading out on the road
for the next week the first three games
are in canada beginning tomorrow night
they take on the toronto maple leafs and
they'll be doing it without forward
william carlson while bill broke his
foot late in the game friday night
against the ducks he'll be out for six
weeks so he joins let's see mark stone
max pacharetti and alex tuck who are all
on the sidelines right now but they move
forward and hope to come together on
this road trip you haven't been out on
the road like this as a group the the
players got to go to montana but a lot
of the staff didn't so this is the first
time we're all together in this
situation we came out a day early to get
acclimatized a little bit and get used
to the the time change